Ole:
*trykker på Host feltet*
Og så skal jeg scanne en QR kode.
Ivik:
Ja, det kan du så ikke gøre..
Patrick:
Der trykker du bare på kurekoden, bare tryk på kurekoden.
Ole:
*Trykker på QR koden*
Ivik:
Ja, lige præcis.
Ole:
Ja, han kom der.
Tidspunktet kunne jeg ikke vælge?
Patrick:
Nej, det er valgt for dig.
Ole:
det har du..
*Peger på opgaven på bordet.*
Patrick:
Nå, det er simpelthen specificeret der? Okay.
Ivik:
Ja, det er så..
Ole:
Det er fair.
Og vi antager at det er tidspunkt det passer, og jeg kan se, at det er ledigt hernede.
*Peger på timeline*
Ivik:
Ja.
Ole:
Og så kan jeg confirm den, hvis det var mig.
*refererer til at der står Mia som hosten*
Ole:
Med mindre, jeg skal sende en invite, det ved jeg ikke.
Ivik:
Ja, man kan så sige i det her tilfælde, der er du værten.
og skal invitere Mia Østergaard.
Patrick:
Ja, nu står der så godt nok Mia der.
Ole:
Nå, men så kan jeg så gå ind og invite en anden.
*Trykker på invite*
*Prøver at trykke på search (Det virker ikke)*
Patrick:
Ja, den kan du så ikke, men det er så sådan at den ser ud.
Ole:
*trykker på en person der skal inviteres*
Og confirm.
*Trykker på confirm*
Ivik:
Og så er mødet reseveret.
Godt, super.
Ole:
Modtager jeg så en bekræftelse?
Ivik:
Det vil du gøre. Det kører via din outlook.
Patrick:
Kan du se at mødet også er dernede nu?
*Peger på timeline*
Ole:
Ja, jeg så godt at den kom med det samme.
Ivik:
Så starter vi igen og går herover.
*skifter til occupied viewet*
Ivik:
Så er den anden opgave der.
*Rækker Ole opgaven.*
Ole:
*Læser opgaven op*.
Så vil jeg gå ind og extende mit møde.
Ole:
Er det udfyldt for mig?
Patrick:
Ja, der vil du så skulle vælge 13:30.
Ole:
13:30 ikke også, og så rette den der.
*Peger på hosten*
Ole:
Og så, når det er gjort, så confirmer jeg der.
*Trykker på confirm*
Patrick:
Jep.
Ole:
Og det var egentlig det.
Ivik:
Yes, super.
Og så skal vi lige se her.
Ivik:
Så får du den her.
*Rækker Ole en ny opgave.*
Ole:
Ja, så går jeg bare ind og trykker end meeting.
*Peger på end meeting*
Patrick:
Prøv.
Ole:
*Siger noget utydeligt*
*Trykker på end meeting*
Ole:
*Læser op fra skærmen*
End meeting? Yes.
Ole:
Og så går mødet ind, og den er frigjort til bookning igen.
Ivik:
Yes.
Patrick:
Yep.